[Music]
primes
stands for program for research in
mathematics
engineering and science it's a free
program
over the course of a year working with
high school students that
engages them with real research projects
engages them with mit faculty graduate
students
who serve as advisors and also they get
to work with their peers who are very
high level
what primes is doing is allowing
talented students to enter a
mathematical community
[Music]
allowing them to become part of a larger
academic community
what is a challenge is to increase
diversity
this is not only underrepresented
minorities but also women
who are severely underrepresented in
mathematics
the program provides a pipeline for
talented high school students of color
to enter
mit enters the field of mathematics
it hasn't been replicated because it
really requires people
like our staff who are very very
dedicated and committed
and i want to thank them and i admire
them for their work to be recognized for
such a prestigious award i mean it's
it's mind-blowing and it's
very very humbling and and
we're just very appreciative of of this
recognition
it's a great honor to to receive this
[Music]
you